[Music]
we are so glad to welcome you to a
special segment of our show
jeopardy warm up it's a new and fun way
to see how much our team here at channel
8 knows about different topics
including a little history of las vegas
our contestants tonight
chris matthews denise valdez and ted
florento
they will have 20 seconds to answer one
question
and whoever wins tonight will take home
the title of the first
jeopardy warm-up winner good luck all
right good luck
i gotta ask you how you feeling you guys
ready to rock
i'm not feeling good i think chris
matthews wants the ringer man
ted looks concerned this looks confident
this is a real wait
it's jeopardy yeah this is the right to
talk smack for the next 24 hours oh
here's the question team okay what is
the oldest casino
currently standing on the las vegas
strip
you have 20 seconds the clock starts now
currently standing
i'm walking down this oh
well
[Music]
wait
okay time is up i have never seen those
three people
so focused the question again what is
the oldest casino
currently standing on the las vegas
strip
now the correct answer is
the flamingo denise valdez what did you
have
oh i'm glad i changed my mind originally
i started with harris
what you got but then i changed to
flamingo denise is correct denise
let's move on to mr chris matthews and
originally denise i had flamingo
and i changed it to caesar's palace i
thought about caesar's trust your
instincts
you are actually incorrect he loves
saying that didn't he ted florendo
he's gonna say it all night here's the
deal guys you guys are good because i
was thinking bugsy seagull too flamingo
sure but i went i'm loving the golden
gate shrimp
okay right and you went to the golden
gate i said golden gate well that is an
out-of-the-box
strip yeah on the strip okay i thought
that we were talking about oldest casino
in general oh the trick was on the strip
so stripped through me i think what
we've learned
is we have an a student and his name is
denise valdez let's clap it up
she's got a fist pump going smack
talking for the next 24 hours chris and
ted
you were incorrect good job
watch it eight news now at 6 30. we're
always on at 8newsnow.com and our app
along with facebook and twitter be sure
to join us tonight
at 11. thanks for watching jeopardy